the Joe Rogan experience Gabi Garcia's
science project and a half that's crazy
what is that I think she's been beaten
uh nothing I'm aware of yeah
how are they gonna find someone a woman
is 240 pounds they're not she's chillin
840 pounds jacked and she's a legit
black belt in Brazilian jiu-jitsu yeah
and she's you know she's legitimately
tough I thought I saw the video of her
grappling with McKenzie Duran and
McKenzie like almost McKenzie beat her
oh did she I think Mackenzie Jitsu match
in jujitsu much but an MMA to get
anybody here yeah I think Mackenzie
either beat her or how to draw one on
advantage something like that but look
it is what it is that's science okay
you're you're doing some stuff you're
doing some stuff to people that it's not
your body's not supposed to have that in
there lady it's not you know I mean it's
it's interesting cuz like like the Bob
Sapp thing like you get to see what
happens like wow okay this is what's
when someone just goes for it yeah and
when pride Ensign anyway was on the
podcast and he and since hilarious he
was detailing the contract he was like
it said in all capital letters
we will not test you for steroids yeah
they're like that's what joy would tell
me all the time Joey Villasenor he's
been in my short over the last couple of
fights
Joey's an excellent fire and he would
say that he said it almost they almost
encouraged encouraged it nonetheless
they basically did encourage it because
they just wanted to see crazy you know
things that like came out of comic books
ya know they wanted you to be jacked
yeah he wanted you to be gigantic yeah
yeah I mean as long as everybody's doing
it I guess I don't think I would never I
wouldn't want to do that even if I had
the choice to do it you wouldn't want I
want to write I get it well that makes
sense and that's why I think people like
you were important for MMA because you
are you're a woman yeah you seem like a
woman you behave like a woman you look
like a woman if you fell someone say
that girl's top 10 UFC fighter you like
what mm-hmm
no way really so you so normal like but
if you saw Gabby Garcia and you know
that girl's smashing people in Japan you
gotta believe me yeah actually
[ __ ] out of this room pushy Hulk's out
flatten me yeah I just like I feel like
it takes the the joy I feel like it
would take the joy out of a victory if
you did steroids yeah yeah well you
would become something different the
reality is a woman become something
different when she starts taking male
hormones you just do
he becomes something different your
tendons strengthen your bone structure
changes your voice deepens you become
much more like a man I mean that's when
you see transgender women when when a
woman rather is a transgender man she
decides she wants to be a man they start
taking testosterone they get beards they
have all sorts of strange things happen
down below and they they start having a
deeper voice and they sound like a man
and that's that's exactly what happens
to a woman when a woman takes steroids
if she's not trying to transition it's
the same thing
he's taking male hormones that make your
muscles grow far larger than they're
supposed to yeah I remember watching a
movie that they did in Thailand it's
called beautiful boxer yes but is the
opposite yes he wanted to be a woman but
I think he did it the right way right if
there's a right way to do it because
well he started as a man and then became
a woman and kept fighting man yes and I
think that someone should have told her
at the time like let's just stop
fighting but stop fighting or this is my
take on it like but she needed to keep
fighting so that she could pay for the
short transition right yeah all right
catch-22 sure ever was one yeah yeah but
it was an elite fighter until the
transition and then you see the skills
start to diminish because there's no
more testosterone when she's fighting
men but if she was fighting women she
would have a giant advantage still over
women and I don't think that's right I
don't think that's very you know one
does no one does except transgender
people transgender people and super
progressive activists who have no idea
how sports work its those are the people
the people that just want inclusiveness
and they just want everyone to be okay
and you know maybe this is the world I'm
looking for I'm looking I'm looking
towards a world where everyone's
included yeah good have a transgender
League
have a transgender division no I'm cool
that I'll be happily happily support
them but you're pretending that that's a
woman and it's not it's a male who's
transitioning to a woman you have an XY
chromosome it's a different thing yeah
you know I'm a hundred percent if a
woman says I want to fight a transgender
woman okay I'm that's fine but like four
leagues to recognize that this is the
same thing and like to say like how
would you feel if all of the UFC's
weight classes in the women's division
were dominated by transgender women I
would feel like there were some I feel
like I should not say so right right
right yeah like I'm gonna get caught up
saying something let me talk for you
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] right yeah you don't have to
say anything and that's how girls feel
right now when there's sports being
dominated track-and-field so fair I mean
I I guess for me I've always been
especially like being a female in a male
dominant sport I've always I've I guess
if I can like like to consider myself a
feminist not not so much a feminist but
I like when I go into the gym I my
teammates look at me as a fighter like
they don't look at me as a female
fighter or anything like that they look
at me as their teammate you didn't mean
and I appreciate that I appreciate that
they trained to treat me as an athlete
and and and all of that good stuff but I
feel like what like at the end of the
day like girls you need to fight girls
and guys need to fight guys we like we
have different strengths than the guys
do and the guys have different strengths
and the girls do and and it's nice for
us to have a place so that we can
showcase our skills yes I agree I think
the only problem that I have with that
transitioning thing is physical
competition that's it
physical competition against the gender
that you supposedly align with yeah you
know you can't do it but here's what you
don't see here's what you don't see you
don't see a lot of transgender men who
want to fight men you don't see a lot of
women who are taking hormones to become
a man who want to fight men yeah good
[ __ ] luck with that ladies good luck
stop this is crazy like this idea that
you
just magically become a woman or you
just magically become a man it's just
not true and athletes recognize it and
rational people recognize it but there's
so much pushback from progressive people
who it's like what percentage of the
population are we even talking about
here we it's not even 1% it's it's a
very strange saying that it's it's
taking over the conversation with
bathrooms and competition in sports and
so many different things
I'm all for inclusiveness and I'm all
for being open-minded and let many
people do you be yourself whatever
yourself is I don't know what yourself
is I don't know what you feel but you
can't compete against women that's it's
that simple
it's really that simple it has to it has
to be something deeper where they you
know it and to me I think it goes back
to like that meant like a mental block
where you where you need some like a
false sense of confidence yes I feel
like
[Applause]